and we are live what's up believe nation
it's good to see you I haven't done an
ama in a long time on youtube i i've had
yes on for the past couple weeks and i'm
usually going live on instagram four
times a week but I miss you guys this
has been fun so I'm good to be back I
want to answer your questions that's
what we got time together we'll see how
long this goes 30 minutes to 60 minutes
we got our time let's make a cam give me
your questions and let me see how it can
help you it's Thursday here I'm super
pumped today's message that I talked
about it's just about mediocrity just
about not accepting the status quo I
think it's easy to be mediocre I think
that's what most people are it's easy to
settle for a good life a good business a
good career a good relationship being a
good parent fight that fight that that
sucks and go for something great make
your life a masterpiece make your
business a mass asset piece make your
relationship a masterpiece if you just
suggest that you're thinking around that
to say what would my life as a
masterpiece look like what would my
business as a masterpiece look like what
would my relationship as a masterpiece
look like just ask yourself that
question forces change forces you to be
better forces you to think in a way
differently than normal and when you're
looking at that piece of paper that you
wrote down these ideas off it should be
motivate and say I'm gonna go out and
create that so you're not just stuck in
a rut stuck doing the same thing it's
like with a good life
make it a masterpiece let's go alright
welcome everybody
I just hit my microphone and I'm super
pumped and excited give me your
questions put it in the the live chat
and let's see we got so kick it off
Salima
is it better to build your personal
brand or business brand I don't know why
you can't do both I think if you can do
a personal brand within the business I
think that's the best way to do it at
the beginning I think people connect
with people I think when you can build
it around yourself your values your
mission I think that's how you beat the
big competition I think if you look at
most industries why do you buy from
coca-cola
why do you buy from Nike why do you buy
from whatever company you know they have
a brand they have a reputation they have
a history if you are an upstart
entrepreneur and you want to start
winning in in an industry that's already
established
why would somebody buy from you instead
of buying from the established
competition if you are brand-new to an
industry why would they buy from you and
so the people who have the reputation in
the customer base and the decades of
experience the reason why they're gonna
buy from you is your story is your
passion is your commitment because when
I buy from you I feel like I'm buying
from a human being who actually cares
about me not from some giant
corporations gonna treat me like a
number and I think one of the biggest
mistakes that entrepreneurs make is they
try to look corporate they try to look
professional they try to model these big
companies and they end up looking boring
and they end up trying to look like
those big companies so and then when I
visit your website and I visit the big
company if I can't tell the difference
then I'm just gonna go with a big
company because I know them I trust them
they've been around forever where you
are what like you are the things can
allow you to win your story your energy
your passion your commitment that's what
will allow you to win and so I think
being able to start with a personal
brand even if you eventually transition
it I think it's I think it's your secret
ticket in it's not that you don't have
to be professional I think you still be
professional and win that's awesome but
be professional and be yourself share
your story everybody on their about page
needs to have their picture on your belt
page on your website you need to have
your picture you need to tell your
foundation story I need to feel your
care I need to know why you started this
business I need to know why this is so
important to you
while you eat sleep breathe this
business why you care so much about your
customers that needs to be there that
needs to be authentic you need to read
that page like yes that's exactly why I
do this business because if you get
fired up reading it other people will
too and I guarantee you if I go to your
big competition and look at their about
page and look at their messaging it's
gonna be BS that's how you start to win
so making it personal
always helps next let's see guys if you
tagged me it's a lot easier to see so
just go at Evan Carmichael so it pops
out in the live chat
let me see what else we got can you tell
us about so this chorus can you tell us
about using Twitter for business Twitter
is still great I love Twitter to be able
to I think you'd be trying to connect
with people one on one if there's
somebody who you want to reach out to
and see and have them see you Twitter is
still the best platform for it if they
are active if they're responding Twitter
is still the best place so if you want
to reach out to some big-name in your
industry or some influencer that you
trying to target Twitter is is the home
I would try to be using Twitter video as
much as possible for whatever reason my
account or my phone does not allow me to
do it anymore and it really frustrates
me but it takes you know 10 seconds to
leave a video message or somebody when
again back to the last question building
a personal brand when I can see you when
I see your face when I see your energy
your passion why are you doing this I'm
much more likely to connect with you
than if you just sent some text and so
specific Twitter strategies one I'd be
making videos every single day the cap I
think is 60 seconds right now no no I
think Twitter's 45 seconds right now my
minute videos get cut so just remember
45 seconds is the VAX
I'd be posting multiple times per day
I'd be using the hashtags a great thing
to look at is if you go to the Twitter
homepage Twitter calm down the left it
shows you trending hashtags in the
moment so I've been looking at can you
can you say anything about those
trending hashtags you know right now
might be Donald Trump talking about you
know border security in the States maybe
you have a point of view on that that
you want to share and maybe you don't
that's fine if you don't have a point of
view don't make up one there's usually
always one per day like Thursday
thoughts Friday feeling Monday
motivation that you can tap into and
it's a great way to get discovery great
get some attention because people are
tweeting about those things and so you
can get on people's radar so making
videos being part of trending
conversations and a third tip I would
say is answer questions so I'd be
looking at people who are in your
industry or people who are asking
questions about your industry I would be
following along different
hashtags that you can connect with and
then be seen as the expert so if
somebody is talking about anything
relating through industry you want to be
in there responding building community
letting people know about you the best
way to generate attention is if you are
giving somebody value they're then going
to come and click on your profile the
worst thing to do is message somebody
say hey come by my sneaker or come by my
kombucha or whatever it is that you're
trying to sell that sucks nobody's gonna
respond to that but if you're giving
them value say wow this person really
helped me
then they're gonna click on your profile
and they're gonna see what you're all
about and that's how we use Twitter for
grow your business good luck ah next
what do we got what do we got we got
let's see em I'm T Ozzy hey Evan thank
you guys for hash tagging every buyer by
mentioning me by the way it's a lot
easier to see oh I just lost her I lost
a quote it's something a totally
different question what's life what is
life I don't know not something I think
about why do you care I don't know I
don't focus too much on that I try think
how I can bring value to your question I
mean I think you want to be doing
something that you're happy with
something that fulfills you want a
regular basis I think that's part of the
beauty now intrapreneurs you get to pick
your path you get to choose the work
that you do I think a lot of people
though as they start becoming an
entrepreneur they end up making a job
for themselves and they're not happy
with what they're doing anymore so
you're like you might be happy for a
year and then whatever has worked for
you now you feel like you have to keep
doing it and then you just stay in a rut
entrepreneurs need variety we love right
we love to come up with new ideas and so
I think to be happy you need to be
constantly evolving and as you evolve
the person you got to bring that to your
business I don't that answers your
question but I hope it helps
next Zack what do most people not know
about marketing I think the biggest
thing that people are lacking in
marketing honestly is just the
authenticity is just sharing you sharing
your story
like what makes Zack so special I think
the reason why you started your
this is born from some kind of pain I
believe your purpose comes from your
pain and so I think people are afraid to
share their story one for fear of being
judged to share some vulnerability that
you had and what people will think of
you if you share that with the world and
to the other reason why people are
afraid to share their story is they
think they're being an egomaniac saying
well it's not about me it's about the
customers about what I do I don't want
people to think like I have a huge ego
and neither those things are actually
true
by sharing your vulnerabilities by
sharing the pain you went through it's a
lot easier for people to relate and
connect with you so I was having this
discussion with somebody who went
through drug rehab drug abuse and now
he's feeling a lot better and he solved
it and he was afraid to share his story
and say that he was addicted to drugs
worried how that might impact the people
around him I believe in the message I
think it's important to help people
overcome a drug addiction I can just
speak to it in generalities but I
haven't been through it so I can't
really get specific with it for
Entrepreneurship I can I can relate I
was making $300 a month I was feeling
like a total loser I was feeling totally
inadequate totally incompetent totally
embarrassed by the lack of success that
I was having I can go back there super
easily and so that's why I can connect
with entrepreneurs who are struggling
that now get their business off the
ground because that was me if I talk
about depression or if I talk about drug
abuse or or alcohol abuse I can't I
could just talk about it in generalities
but I can't go specific because I
haven't experienced it and so that's the
thing if you want to help people you
have to share your story you can you can
get something okay from me on that but
if I actually went through it I had a
powerful story you're gonna connect with
me and then you're gonna listen to the
advice so that's the first part and the
second one was just around ego this was
much harder for me to digest people kept
one and the most popular the most common
top ten request on my channel is for me
people want to know what are your top
ten rules for success Evan Carmichael
people always want to know what's your
store what are you about and in the
beginning I was always from the mindset
of well what is it Who am I I mean I'm
profiling Steve
jobs and Kanye and Oprah and all these
big-time people why do you want to hear
from me and when I took a long time to
recognize I want to hopefully encourage
you to get there faster is understanding
that your journey is learning so that by
you sharing what you've gone through and
what you are still trying to go and
accomplish it's a journey that other
people will be inspired by even if you
haven't learned anything yet even even
if you are gonna start a weight loss
journey for example you weigh 300 pounds
you want to get down to 200 and you
don't know how you're gonna do it by
just by sharing the journey say I'm
gonna start today's day one I'm going to
go for a 15 minute run and I'm gonna try
to eat healthy today just sharing that
that's inspiration for the people it's
not about you don't make it like your
journey becomes interesting for me to
watch and then that can be inspiring for
me to want to go off and do the same
thing by watching you doing something
that is different is courageous is bold
and you might think a weight loss
journey isn't that bold but for a lot of
people it is bold it is courageous by
you doing it it gives permission for
other people to do it too by you having
a tough conversation where you going and
reaching for your goals by you waking up
and trying to chase down a dream even if
you don't hate it yet
it gives permission for other people to
go off and do the same thing which is
why your story becomes super important
and so I think that's missing in
marketing I don't think people talk
about their story enough I don't think
people share their real authentic point
of view enough I think people are too
concerned about being professional I
think most people's messages suck not
that they don't have a deep message
they're just not expressing it I think
if you look at people who are on you
know YouTube or Instagram or snapchat
they're making video content it's boring
it's safe it's not actually who they are
because they're afraid of being judged
and they're afraid of sharing their real
humanity so I think that's how you win
that's I think that's people who speak
truth whether you agree with the truth
or not those are the people ultimately
win and so figuring out what you stand
for and then how to express that daily
becomes super important
next success steps for Instagram from
Salima
so Instagram is my new my new favorite
and that's not my new favorite that's
not true YouTube's in my favor but you
Instagram is quickly becoming has become
my number two I'm spending a lot of time
there an Instagram it took me six years
to get to 6,000 followers because I was
mailing it in and now we're at 13 and a
half in a couple months so more than
doubled because I've been taking a lot
more seriously couple things to keep in
mind one make it beautiful Instagram is
about beautiful it's got to be stunning
it's got to be appealing to the eye
if it doesn't look nice people will not
consume it so trying to figure out how
to package your message in a beautiful
looking picture or video is super
important that was the one of the
biggest shifts that I made from just
throwing a bunch of text on the picture
to now really focusing on design even if
you have a design template if you look
at my Instagram I do these quotes and
they're on a white background and it's
the same background each time but it's
it's clean it's nice it's beautiful and
that starts to get results to go live go
stories get interactive as much as the
posts are about beauty the the live and
the stories are are are not it's ghetto
it's personal it's here's my life here's
what I'm going through it's meant to be
like you're feeling like this and it's
shaky people are consuming stories like
crazy and they're super important they
just launched IG TV which allows you to
make videos that are for most people 10
minutes long for some people up to 60
minutes long so they're experiencing
with long-form content whether they
getting into that or not you can you can
see but definitely making stories at
least three times a day this is a
challenge that I gave Lilly and Alex on
my team and anybody who wants to be a
thought leader and share your message
which as entrepreneurs you should even
if you are selling trucks you should be
a thought leader on why your trucks are
the best like what's what not from
ownership perfective but like what is
the thing in the truck industry that is
missing have a point of view you're
certain is for reason you are a thought
leader and so practice
on Instagram stories three times a day
minimum it disappears in 24 hours so
don't freak out and if you're just
getting started nobody's watching you
anyway and so developing the skill to be
able to give a message in 15 seconds
which is how long and Instagram story is
is a fantastic skill to learn that will
you can use for the rest of your life
even if Instagram blows up and goes away
and then third I'd be using hashtag
strategies really well if you are just
if you're a smaller account on your
posts I would be saying target content
target tags that have 20,000 posts or
less and be using 15 to 20 tags on every
post that you make and I'd be looking at
making at least one a day I'd love to
get you to at least three a day go on
Instagram if you want to take it
seriously and get results and make sure
you tag inside your stories as well
always use a geolocation tag so if it's
your city or a local place that you're
at if it's a popular place geo locate
your tag as well as hash tags you can
rank for bigger hash tags in your
stories it's still more about recency
than relevancy where in your post you
have to use more specific hash tags if
you want to try to stand out as you get
bigger then you can go after the bigger
hash tags but to try to rank for
motivation or entrepreneur or any of
those things you're not as a small
account on your posts in your stories
you might so put them in your stories
those are my three tips for Instagram
great I love it next a droopy how do you
pitch your business to someone you look
up to and get their attention okay first
of all I would say one you should be a
known quantity to them so I would pay
attention to who this person is and
where they are actually interacting the
most so if you look at me for example I
am interacting the most right now
probably on Instagram so if you're
trying to get my attention you want to
pitch me something I should know who you
are on Instagram I should see your face
in all of my comments I should know that
you are supporter when you end up
pitching me something I should say oh
wow it's this person I love them they're
always so supportive of me and not some
random stranger even if you've been
for three years even if you've been a
fan forever right be a known quantity so
one look at where they that person is
the most active themselves personally
not their team but them they are
responding to then be in that community
as much as possible every single post
you are sharing you are commenting on
you are giving your perspective not just
a fist bump or a happy face but you are
you are writing out content you need to
be a known quantity there are people who
are part of all of my communities
youtube twitter facebook instagram even
snapchat who if they ask him for
something i would take a look at it and
do my best to try to support it even if
i had nothing to do with my business
just because they've given so much to
the community that i want to help them
out as much I will fight to try to help
them out that was something totally
outside what I know or or what I can do
then at least is on my radar for the
future but a lot of people end up just
pitching me and I have no idea who you
are and so the chance of you getting an
open is is much lower getting a response
is much lower or me caring as much is
much lower so you got to give first and
you may feel like you've been watching
them and then you've you know you've
been consuming their content and you
know them so well but they have no idea
who you are so you got a you got to
adjust that ratio and then three as I'm
reaching out I would try first to reach
out with some kind of value I try to
reach out to support them I would try to
reach out to interview them on your on
your podcast or your YouTube channel I
wouldn't go out as my first interaction
being a hard sales pitch so that's my
advice
good luck next deep deep hunch you guys
tagged me it's a lot easier for me to
see deep punch you I want to get into a
place with more opportunities like the
u.s. where I can learn a lot and later
pay back to society so one great figure
out a way to do it whether it's through
education with us through a job and to
the flipside of that is it doesn't
matter you could be great any
where you can learn anywhere now like
the Internet has opened up everything if
if you want to make that your goal
awesome and work towards it and make a
plan and whether it's in one year or two
years or however long it's in ticket to
get there you've mapped out your plan to
do it and at the same time don't wait on
that don't wait
what do you try to accomplish what are
you trying to learn what are you trying
to build start now don't wait until some
magical fairy comes and drops some magic
dust on you and you end up in the u.s.
and because you are not in the u.s. now
you can't achieve your dreams that's BS
start from wherever you are right now
you can Wayne from wherever you are
right now there are people who have one
who had less than what you already have
right now who came from worse and where
you are right now they figured it out
they won you can too I just I you can
make that as a plan that gets to the
u.s. awesome I just hate it when people
use that as an excuse I can't win
because I'm not in the US you could win
from anywhere in the world when you
adopt that belief system then you
actually start to win Matthew what's
your opinion on volunteering again
experience I love it just make sure
you're gonna learn what you need to
learn the the the thing about getting
the job is to learn not just getting
paid to pay your bills which is okay but
to learn and so if if you're doing
volunteering if you can't get a job you
want to volunteer to get the experience
that's great
people pay to go to university you pay
to go to college you take on mountains
of debt that you're paying off for for a
long time we're here through
volunteering you can get that without
having to pay anything and so I'd just
be making sure that the time that I'm
spending is worth the result and and to
add a little bonus on there I don't
think it's just volunteering at places
that typically bring on volunteers you
think of volunteering it's usually
nonprofits NGOs you know those types of
organizations I would look at how can I
volunteer with businesses how can I get
involved in campaigns that they're
working on one just to learn and listen
if you provide a ton of value the
chances of them you actually get me
hired to work there is is gonna be
pretty high so you know as an example I
started a new series on my youtube
channel called B'Elanna becoming and
we've done five episodes I think so far
four or five and it's it's basically a
vlog series follow me around you guys
have seen the becoming videos a lot of
you are fans I love it thank you for the
support that started with two guys local
in Toronto there there are film crew and
they did one episode for me for free
they volunteered said hey we're gonna
follow you around for a whole day we're
gonna cut it together in a video won't
cost you anything let's just see where
it goes like okay sure let's do it and
the first video was 40 minutes long
you follow me the entire day and I loved
it I loved what they did it's two guys
different angles I love how we edited it
together a lot the music you put on that
was a great addition to the channel
showing a different side of what I'm
doing
and after that one video I hired them
for an annual deal they did a great job
like okay I love this video guys how do
we make this work that we do one video a
week for the next year as our next step
now it may happen that quickly for you
or it may take longer right it may take
three months or six months of
volunteering before you get an
opportunity but if you do a great job
and you're volunteering and it's at a
company the chance of you getting hired
it's gonna be pretty high so when you go
in its I'm going in to learn and I'm
going to prove myself and I might create
an opportunity for me to learn it to win
so go look I would look at volunteering
even if they don't have a volunteer
position on their website which most
people won't so don't just look at the
NGOs next Eric how's your day going I
love it I'm on my days great Thursday
publicly seen day for me interviews
podcasts all that stuff so I I missed
this I mentioned at the top I miss
hanging out with you guys I missed
answering your questions every Thursday
I make a commitment to go live on
YouTube whether with a guest or a may
style like this and I've had guests for
the past few weeks which has been
interesting I've learned a lot but I
like this too I like just be able to
help one on one and see where the
conversation goes next a droopy how do
you promote a creative event that you
believe would provide value to money so
if this is a local event like it's not
an online event that you can attend
I would look at one making partnerships
with people who are in the local
community brick-and-mortar who could
help promote and support it so you know
look at the people who already are
serving your target customers and see
how you can strike up some kind of deal
so if the event is a dance event you
know we have dance events here drama
dance salsa great I would look at who
are the other companies in the Dane's
industry who are not direct competitors
so maybe it's a dance you company maybe
it's a dance video company maybe it's a
dance clothing company and saying hey
we're launching this event is there a
way to partner with you to help give it
some more exposure and maybe they come
to the event they have a booth for free
or a table for free or whatever the
arrangement that you end up working out
find local partners who serve the same
audience as you do but the they sell
something different than what you do -
I'd be looking at local media I look at
crafting a story whatever the angle is
whether it's your age or your
demographic background or the cause that
you're trying to promote if it's a dance
event you know I can look at it from a
perspective of Toronto entrepreneur I
can look it as a perspective of getting
active and moving around and the
importance I could look at at the
perspective of meeting people and being
social in this age of everybody being in
their phones
this craft interesting story and then
would pitch local media I would pitch
all the local media organizations in -
in my area and say here's this store and
try to try to understand the publication
that you're talking to and give them a
good story reporters are always looking
for stories so if you give them a story
that's not super promotional but this is
actually a story behind it
then you're much more likely to get a
yes and they a lot of times for me
they've just copy and pasted my story to
them into their paper that's a little
bit lazy the better reporters won't do
that but you get exposure for free and
it's amazing
at the same time a lot of these online
local places have directory listings for
events upcoming events so I'm looking at
going to Boston next weekend
this weekend next weekend and I was
looking at what's happening in Boston
what events are happening in Boston
what's going on I want to I want to do
something fun with my wife when if we go
and so I go to the Boston whatever
website and look at their upcoming
events right like you want to be listed
on those websites for yourself if I look
at Toronto my assistant every week pulls
together a list of what's happening in
the weekend in Toronto every weekend and
then I look at that list and I make a
decision what to do with Nina I have to
plan my weekends as a surprise for Nina
every week and so my assistant helps me
in pulling together the events that he
thinks we would be interested in and so
you want to be on all those websites
right and in third I would say local
influencers so people who maybe don't
have a brick-and-mortar business a more
online focused who have a voice in the
community and again letting them know
what you're up to the story the mission
the message to get their support their
buying to help you be able to grow the
fastest way to grow so all of these have
have connections to partnerships right
the fastest way to grow is to find
somebody who already has your target
audience and find a way to work with
them
whether it's local media businesses
online influencers lots of different
ways to go and good luck with your event
next Astrid I prefer to hire from
volunteers this means they really care
about the work yes yeah I mean I've
hired lots of people after volunteer
work as well now the thing is it has to
be good just because you volunteer
doesn't mean you're bringing value
understand that as a volunteer coming in
you are also taking away even though
you're not being paid you're taking away
time you're taking away resources from
the people who are working there right
so do they have to give you a desk well
that's somebody else's desk potentially
do they have to mentor you and train you
to get up to speed on a project that's
time that could be spent on something
else so don't think of it as you're
giving so much right you're taking from
at the beginning so you need to bring
crazy values that they they will then
want to hire you and it's honestly not
that hard like to get a job after
volunteer is not that difficult because
most employees are businesses they mail
it in most employees they just do enough
work that they don't get fired that's
the sad reality they complain about
their job they hate their life and
they're not really putting a lot of
effort into their work that's that's
most employees ninety-five percent of
America wakes up and drive to a job that
they hate and so if you are there now
bringing insane value and your volunteer
ship is about to finish it's like how do
we do you want them fighting to keep you
onboard fighting to open up budget
fighting to say how can how can you say
you're bringing so much insane value
that we need to keep you onboard so
super helpful important next V what's
your start on partnering with a company
that owns animals I would like to have
them in my work as a photographer
partnering with a company that owns
animals I would like to have them in my
work as a photographer so I guess it
depends on the animals when I think when
when I read partnering I think equity
partnership as a default I don't think
that's what you mean and if you do I
don't think that's the right path to go
but I would look at just a smaller scale
partnership where you're both benefiting
so in that last conversation I had about
promoting a local event partner with
people who have your target audience is
find a way to work together if you're a
photographer and you want to you want to
take pictures of animals whether that's
you know simple animals like cats and
dogs and birds and mice and household
animals or wild animals like tigers and
elephants and lions and giraffes and
what are those things it looks like I'm
just thinking about those things look
like a big guinea pig like this giant
guinea pig I can't I don't know why my
my brain went there but anyway if you're
a photographer these are all businesses
that need pictures so if you approach
them and you said I'd love to take some
pictures of your animals and you can use
them on your Instagram you can use them
on your website and you can use them
wherever it is that they could
potentially use them and then you get
pieces for your portfolio that's
actually probably pretty easy ask I've
done that with photographers like hey we
want to photograph you for our portfolio
are you okay with it
like yeah let's just let's just set up a
time and make it happen
that may even lead to them hiring you to
do more pictures because what you
provided was so amazing and great that
they don't want to lose you I think you
bring lots of value to that relationship
if you're doing something like dogs and
cats this is so easy any any pet store
any Humane Society there's tons of it
even owners who have you know
nice-looking cats and dogs even
Instagram dog and cat accounts I might
be local to you is great if you're
looking at wild animals you have a
little less to pick from but but I could
see a local zoo wanted to work with you
I could see a traveling show wanting to
do work with you I think you bring a lot
it's just a matter of reaching out and
showing them how you can use it showing
samples of your work and if you keep it
up you might get hired by them good luck
A+ Academy I know you've made an
investment for learning skills so is it
necessary to invest if you are just a
beginner beginner entrepreneur I think
the best investment you make is in
yourself I think the best investment is
is in here is improving your mindset and
I think it does have to cost anything
besides time you know at the beginning
you don't have any money but you've got
time and so so use that there's so much
content that's available for free think
about what happens on my youtube channel
this is almost all free content you know
like okay this is my books that cost 15
bucks or whatever it is but all the
videos are free and here you get to
learn from Elon Musk and Steve Jobs and
Oprah Winfrey and some of the best
things that they've ever said and my
team has helped me put together all of
that research pouring through all of the
videos and all the interviews to find
the 20 minutes of great nuggets just for
you for free and whether you love my
stuff I mean if you're here you're a fan
of the channel great but if if you you
get tired of me or I'm not bringing
value to you anymore
there's so many other people that you
can learn from too even just in the
entrepreneur space you can learn from
Gary Vee and Grant Cardone and Marie
Forleo and whoever it is there's lots of
different people different styles that
maybe resonate with them more than me
awesome goal learn from them it's never
been easier and it's never been cheaper
to get the education and so you don't
need to go out and spend a lot of money
you just have to dedicate time on a
regular basis to learn and whether you
learn best from a video I like video I
learned the best stood video it's why I
made this channel because for me reading
a book is good but not as good as
watching video and listening to
something kills me I can't do podcasts I
really struggled through podcasts
because I'm not an auditory learner at
all
so that was the only way to learn I
would I would force myself to do it but
thankfully there's a lot of other
sources and a lot of great videos in my
favorite channel is my own channel I
think I learned the most from my own
channel I make the videos selfishly for
me to learn then I share that learning
with you guys and so it's it's never
been easy to learn I think it's just
making a commitment every day to put it
as part of your routine that you spend
30 minutes unlearning good luck mark I
have a deep philosophy podcast and we
talk about what what it feels what I
feel is unprofessional for the business
world should I slip my podcast into one
side philosophy one side business
inspiration know this is super important
if I think I think the way that you win
is by combining those two things
together any time and this isn't just
for podcast this is for every business I
think so many entrepreneurs are stuck in
the world of do I do this who do this
which one is better for me the answer is
to do both combine them not not sit both
separately combine them because if you
only do one you won't be the best of
that thing and you will lose if you're
only talking about philosophy there's
other philosophy podcasts that will be
better than yours
and if you only talking about business
or inspiration there will be other
business podcasts that are better than
yours and so you're always going to be
this junior version and never have
success we're what makes you amazing is
you bring philosophy and business
together that is what you could be the
best at and so you need to shrink those
two smush them together and make that
the awesome podcast and that's what you
get known for so
if you look at what I've done with my
channel the content is diverse but all
stems from belief and what believe looks
like to me so every video was is
positive it's always it's always
positivity even if I disagree with
somebody or I think they have a lot of
negativity to them
I'll only pull out the positive points
that believe worthy points and that's
what I share in the videos and so people
try to copy me all the time I spend zero
time looking the people who are copying
me if you're just trying to copy me
you're always just gonna be a junior
version of what I'm doing so I'm not war
I don't look in the rear view mirror I
don't care about the people who are
copying me
you'll never you'll never out Evan Evan
and that's what I want for you I want
people to not was his name I missed it
sorry it's further up you people never
out you you and so for you to win you
have that should be you and I think
combining those things together as one
business philosophy into business is how
you will win Henry what's the best
advice you can give to a person starting
a new software business go find a
customer go build the business around
the customer my first business was a
software company and at the beginning it
was just built around my partners and
their needs inside their specific
research lab and then it became hard to
get traction and momentum because it was
only designed around their needs is a
great place to start from what you
really care about but when you start
involving your customers or potential
customers that's when you start to win
and so all of the growth a lot of the
features that we added in we would we
would build them for so some would say
hey can you add this feature to your
software yes it'll cost this amount of
money that would usually be a break-even
for us or just a little bit more but
then we rolled that into the software
that then got rolled out to all of our
customers right and now we had a bigger
feature set that we could charge more
money for and so spend less time
thinking on your couch around the dining
room table thinking and planning and
thinking and planning and more time
talking to your customers and more time
understanding what their problems are
and what they would be willing to pay
for and the best way to build a business
the best way to get started is to build
around one
customer their needs their problems
create something custom that then you
can package into a product for other
people and then as you keep getting
feedback from your customers you keep
pouring into your software good luck
Wow open thank you so much no problem
mark hope it helps guys tag me it's a
lot easier to see what else software
business we talked about nsk money and
all materialistic things motivate me to
work hard I think if I had more money I
will be able to help more people so you
won it's true if you have more money you
can help more people but by spending
your money on materialistic things you
cannot help more people I think people
need money I think businesses need money
I think I think people have a messed up
view on money I think I don't think many
people have a healthy understanding of
money I think some people think money is
everything that's all that matters we
just chasing money money money all the
time
and you know somebody walks into your
office and you see them as your next
suit or your next car your next watch is
how you see just see dollars and you
don't actually care about that human
being I think that's wrong some people
think money is evil money is root of all
evil right and and I think that's wrong
too I think those people is a lot of
entrepreneurs who feel that way they
don't charge enough they don't feel like
they're worth it I think a lot of
entrepreneurs could raise their prices
30 percent and not see any impact
negative on their business people don't
charge enough for what they're doing
because they don't value themselves
enough and because they're afraid of
asking for money I think both
perspectives are wrong I think money is
super important it's just not number one
there has to be something above money
your mission your purpose your value
there's something that's number one and
then money can be number two three or
four money is not number 128 it's not
that far down it's gotta be high money
is important even if you're running a
charity money is important and having
money allows you to do more money allows
you to hire a team money allows you to
market yourself more money allows you to
make more products money allows you to
have a bigger impact but if you're
taking money out of the system to then
go buy your car
how are you helping more people people
aren't gonna be helped because you've
bought a new car and so if I could say
anything it'd be to encourage you to try
to shift the perspective of I'm doing
this to try to buy money so I can buy
new clothes or something materialistic
and say I'm in this because money is
important but I want to help people
solve a specific problem I want to have
a big impact and money will allow me to
get there and do it that's when you
start to win and if you look at any of
the people that have had real success
real success look at that people who are
at the top of their game in any field
money is not the number one motivator
it's important it might be number two
three four but it's not number one and
so model those people good luck
Abdul what financial structure do you
advise for people should we store our
money in the banks if you store your
money in the bank you're losing money
the rate of interest that you get on
just putting money in a bank account is
less than inflation so net you start
actually losing money just having it in
the bank account now decide on how to
put your money in really depends on your
risk tolerance if you're if you're
becoming an entrepreneur you might want
to decide the bet on yourself and say
this is the best investment that I can
make and I'm gonna use the money I have
to try to launch my business I'm not a
huge fan of going into debt or spending
money before I'm making money so I would
much more encourage you to invest your
time your energy your hustle your heart
more than your dollars on something if
you have extra dollars I'd be looking at
making some investments if you have no
idea what you're doing if you have zero
interest in stock market or anything
else I would just buy an exchange-traded
fund it's the lowest fee rate and it
just kind of it follows the market if
you don't want to be a stock picker
if you don't want to have to worry about
where your money's going and you just
want over time you're gonna win I put it
into an ETF and then spend your time
focus on building a business
don't just even a bank account you will
lose you will lose money the only caveat
to do in a stock ETF is if you are going
to be retired
anytime soon or you need that money and
a short window then I would put in
something safer like a bond where you're
guaranteed a result if you know you need
that money in two years the stock market
might crash in two years and so you've
lost that money now if you have a longer
horizon it's gonna keep going up the the
market will make those gains back but if
you need that money in that window then
you should be a little more safe with it
put it but even putting it into a
government bond or even some corporate
bonds you'll make more than just leaving
it in a bank account where you're losing
money to inflation good luck positive
Academy thanks a lot by the way when you
interview people oops
lots of questions when you interview
people you need to spend some money
right now why why do you need to spend
money to any of you people I interview
people all the time on this channel who
did I do last week we had Novak
Djokovic's coach a manager he's managed
three number-one professional tennis
players I've had who else TD jakes on
this channel it done Brian Tracy we've
done some big thought-leaders just like
this
this guy doesn't have to cost anything
like it's great I have a microphone but
before that I didn't have a microphone
you have enough in your laptop you have
a laptop you can do it you don't elapse
up gabor a laptop you can do a google
hangout Lily Lily who's in the chat went
to do a couple of interviews with people
and she use her phone just like this
here it is use your studio you got it
all right here that's enough don't worry
about what you don't have
stop thinking about what you don't have
instead think about what you can do with
what you do have the resourcefulness
that's the ultimate resource what else
guys again tag me a lot easier for me to
see buh buh buh buh buh what else what
else what else
how what there was something how do you
know if it suits you how do you know
something suits you I forgot a loss of
question something RL here
Matthew no not Matthew anyone I lost it
sorry guys keep posting questions I'll
find it
what is a good inexpensive camera for
content I don't know I don't pay
attention to gear the gear doesn't
matter
start with your cell phone so with your
cell phone until you make enough money
to buy a camera that's it and then when
I so when I got started I either
borrowed gear or used what I had a
little flip phone a flip camera back in
the day and then I would go once I made
a little bit of money I went to Costco
and I bought their entry-level Sony
camcorder and I went to Costco because
they had the most gracious return policy
so if it didn't if it wasn't working out
I think it was 30 days or 60 days you
could still take the camera back and get
a full refund and then I slowly upgraded
my camera to the highest level that
Costco had and again as I was making
money my channel I put it back in to buy
better gear and was at the highest end
camera that Costco sold and then
eventually I outgrew what Costco sold
because they didn't have higher end
cameras I bought a bought a better
camera and now I
I mean I'm filming this off of a this is
the Logitech 4k camera at the time it
might still be the only 4k webcam on the
market so it's highest quality but it's
still just a webcam it's not that
expensive I'm gonna say 200 bucks or
something it's not it's not Bank
breaking but now I hire a film crew
right I've got I've got the two guys who
follow me around for the vlog and I've
got a camera guy who comes in once a
month and helps me film but still a lot
of the videos if you ever see this
background here it's filmed off of a web
cam you know $200 webcam and this
microphone now is more expensive but for
years I used the blue Yeti microphone
which was probably about the same 150
bucks something like that that doesn't
have to cost a lot so I don't know I I
wouldn't worry about what camera to use
I would start with your cell phone when
I go traveling and I'm filming videos
I'm I still use this channel with 1.3
almost 1.4 million subscribers I still
film off of my cell phone so start with
that and here's the thing it's not just
the money
like I hate spending money till I'm
making money so it's not just the money
of buying the camera
it's just a thought process people spend
time thinking about the wrong things in
that time thinking of what camera to
spend your money on what camera is the
best you could have made 15 videos off
of this and had some momentum right the
most important thing always gonna be you
not to gear that you're using and so
just start just start building momentum
feel what that momentum feels like that
actually has some attraction going and
then you can worry as you get any money
where you're gonna spend it okay next I
do pre how could I provide you value on
IG and could I interview you if you want
to interview me let's do it interview me
let's do it you know emails my assistant
Sandra at Evan Carmichael comm link like
go to the replay of this video find this
spot and send her the link I do pretty
771 we're gonna do an interview together
next dr. Stan what do you what do you
use to market yourself some business you
ever use Google Ads I do not use Google
Ads Google Ads are our we haven't found
the ROI I've got better results from
Facebook ads and Google Ads but still we
don't do a lot on Facebook Ads we do two
main things one is we build an amazing
service so when I when I took over the
business and I hired Alex I gave him a
list of 10 different ways to grow the
business here are 10 marketing ways that
we can grow our business you have to
pick two we can't do 10 amazingly well
if we try to do an all ten we're gonna
suck at 10 you have to pick two one of
them is thought leadership so I'm
picking one for you you have to want to
be a thought leader and that means
creating content making videos posting
the Instagram sharing your thoughts I
don't want to work with entrepreneurs
who do not want to be thought leaders
you have to be an you may not be good at
it yet but you have to have an opinion
on how the world should be you have to
be fighting for good and you have to
share that I believe that's the best way
to build a business and so I only want
to work with entrepreneurs who want to
be thought leaders so I do my workshop
in September
helping thought-leaders make money from
their business here in Toronto so that
had to be won and then I gave him the
other nine you get to pick what you want
to do and the one that he picked was a
remarkable service and so the number one
way that we actually get customers for
our business is word of mouth is
providing such a great service that
people leave us and go back to their
work and in between sessions they say to
their friends you have to go sign up at
Toronto this house is the best thing
ever
our goal is for the class you take with
us to be the highlight of the week but
this is the best part of your week this
is what you look forward to every single
week my goal for every instructor in the
business is for that instructor to be
the people in the class their favorite
teacher of all time we teach adults so
you've had hundreds of teachers growing
up through elementary school grade
school high school college university
higher education after that you've had
hundreds of teachers of all your
teachers and professors I want my
teachers to be the greatest teachers in
the history of you so that's sustain you
that's the bar now we're working towards
it but the goal of having a remarkable
experience of having an experience that
is so great that people want to make a
remark about it and so that's how a
majority of our business comes in the
other is and through content so through
SEO on our website through Instagram
stories and content people find this
people be become a part of the community
they you know find us who those avenues
and upcoming signing up for class so
those are the two main ways we've done
historically very little of any
advertising and that's a missed
opportunity to be honest we could be
making more I would pick face book
before you before Google though I'm even
Instagram before Google I think those
are it's it's not as expensive and you
can get targeted people better but we
haven't done it because we still have to
work on the other stuff and you can't do
everything well so when you have you
know limited resources like we all do
I might have a little more resources but
it's still limited it's not infinite
resources then you have to focus on how
you're gonna use those resources
including your time
to the best of your abilities and right
now our service is really good but it
could be way better and that's still the
number one focus as well as the thought
leadership is pretty good but could be
way better so those are the two channels
we focused on from a marking perspective
to grow the business and so we're
sticking in that Lane it's easy to get
distracted as I go try this and try this
and try this and as entrepreneurs we
love doing that you know we love trying
to new which is good sometimes it tastes
but you can't get distracted you have to
stay focused on your mission and the
path because if you just taste tasting a
whole bunch of stuff it's great in the
early days to fight figure out what your
passion is and what's working but as you
get established and as you know where
you're going you have to stay the course
and not get too distracted by the shiny
objects around you next Drako how we
doing on time eight minutes
we went for an hour almost this is I
love you guys Drako Evan a year ago or
so I used to run at three I'm having
this Law of Attraction mindset and
watching your videos this year I got
diagnosed with heart rhythmic problems
it got me anxious okay
that sucks is there a question around
that Drake oh I don't I'm not sure
exactly how to help you I don't have
heart rhythmic problems so I be looking
to find as much help as I can if the 3
a.m. waking up and and watching videos
is helping you then I would keep doing
it and if it's not then I would I would
shift I think so here's the thing
somebody asked me about my routine and
how static it is and my routine I think
your routine has to change with time
my routine change is probably in a major
way once a quarter it's not like sit
down and plan it once a quarter I have a
day my calendar to analyze it but
whenever you feel something is not quite
working because you have grown you will
grow as a human being you will have new
interests and new passions and new
things you want to try out and you will
just you will grow then your schedule
has to reflect your growth you have to
chain
get up if you kept doing the same thing
like if something motivates you a year
ago and you're on fire chances are that
won't work as well anymore a year later
so you need to constantly adjust and
tweak so my schedule is still still with
the goal the the aim the ambition of
having believe injected every morning to
what I'm doing but how I execute that
chips and so you need to shift your
schedule as you as you shift your
priorities and you shift your your
mindset in your growth it's all I got on
that one good luck I feel bad for you
with the heart problem I hope it gets
better uh next Salima how do you
overcome fear of imperfection
perfectionism sucks perfectionism hold
so many people back it's myself too my
first business I lost a 40 million
dollar deal because I was trying to do
the perfect thing instead of actually
just getting started in doing it that
that fear or that painful lesson shocked
me out of my perfectionism because by
default I like to be perfectionist too
but that experience shocked me out of it
hopefully you don't have to go through
that and lose a 40 million dollar deal
to reduce some of your perfectionism
what I would try to do though is every
time I feel like I'm trying to be too
perfect to train myself to go off and do
that thing to just release it and just
make it better so an example for my
website I decided one day that I was
going to completely change my business
model where I had you know hundred
thousand pages on my website getting
content advertising dollars lots of
stuff and I just I didn't switch it up
you know I was gonna make just a one
page I wanna I want to sell the world's
biggest problem untapped human potential
and so I made a one-pager that I made
myself just a graphic my entire website
gone one graphic and why I put that up
there was because it was public and was
only one page and it was super unclear I
knew would motivate me to then make it
better even now it's still just graphics
most of the pages on my website are just
graphics is no CSS you can't search
anything it's it's terrible from s
CEO perspective is brutal just brutal
which is great because it builds
momentum and it forces me to improve it
and make it better and so we went from
the one-page graphic to I don't know 15
or 20 pages of graphics I mean still
needs to get better and I think what
ends up happening with with the
perfectionist side is you just keep
tinkering and trying and tinkering and
tinkering and tinkering it's never
perfect and there's always something new
to add there will always be something
new to add you know you have a list of
ideas that list of ideas doesn't shrink
your list of ideas will only grow and
grow and grow and grow and grow and so
at some point you have to do and so if
you ever feel like you're being too
perfect I would I would try to embrace
that and then do the thing just to feel
it just to get used to it and hopefully
you don't end up losing out on a huge
deal like I did to jolt you into it
next how do you how do you get rid of
bad memories and regrets in the past I'm
21 years old and I want to start being
successful but I think about bad
memories and regrets one I would say you
need to focus on what the positive thing
is that you're trying to build you have
to get excited you have to be you have
to think about a world that you want to
create and you and go off and make that
world - I would say your your purpose
does come from your pain and so all of
these negative things that you've gone
through chances are now if you if you
are if you figured out your way through
or you're still struggling to get
through it chances are you want to make
that path a little bit easier for other
people and so the answer to your success
might lie in these painful moments in
these bad memories and regrets to help
others not face the same thing and so I
don't think you just try to shut them
out this is a part of you this is made
you who you are
now you want to make it easier for
people to not go down that same road I
love helping entrepreneurs because of
how painful it was for me to get my
business off the ground and I can relate
to all the struggles and lack of
self-worth and lack of momentum and just
feeling like a total idiot I can relate
to all that that was me so I want to
make the road a little bit easier
so I think combining both those things
thinking about a better world that you
want to create and then thinking about
the pain you've been through and how you
want to make that pain less for the
people who come next and then maybe the
third one I just look at what my my
morning routine was my habits were are
you doing the thing that helps you feel
guided by success on a daily basis it
was watching a video or reading a book
or having a conversation or coaching
somebody else through it changing your
habits to reflect the person that you
want to become is super important two
minutes left what do we got any advice
you can get to teenagers start start
start start start start don't don't
think of your youth as a disadvantage
it's an advantage young people have
never had more opportunities to win get
out of your head and just start that
thing that you want to do it's possible
believe that it's possible find people
who have done it model the success put
it to work start start start start start
starts all right start go next
one last question one minute what do we
got where we got Bernadette finally
still polished my memoir however the
target audience is not the same for my
business which is in the startup phase
should i market my book should i market
my book to book target audience or or
business this brings me back to the
question we had before shutting my
podcast around philosophy or business
you mix them you mix them the fact that
you have set up your book to be a
different market than your business you
are not you are not being an authentic
to you entrepreneur Bernadette if you
have all these different silos that are
different pieces of you you will lose in
all of them where you need to mix them
together in a way that nobody else can
do it and that's what makes Bernadette
will is so special so I'll find a way to
mix my business of the book that
audience the the book into the business
deines it's the same audience my thing
is all about belief that's that's
constant through everything that I do do
you got to figure out what you stand for
Bernadette and that's a consistent theme
throughout and if you continue to split
things up into so many different avenues
none of them will go as well as I could
mix them together good luck guys thank
you it's noon a lot of fun it's already
been an hour it's crazy it's crazy
anyway looking forward to coming back if
I've given you any energy today I hope
that you pour it into your business and
do something that that is meaningful
that matters is still tons of time left
today that you can say today mattered
when you rest your head you're on your
pillow tonight I want you to feel like
the work that you did today was inspired
and that mattered and that you're making
today a masterpiece don't let it go to
waste guys thank you for the love I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon